I don't want to get too serious here but
I want to address this you you had a
double mastectomy and how are you how
you no one does that
except you how are you I'm doing really
well yeah I'm doing really well I'm in
remission and I you know I went through
a lot last year and yeah not to be
totally intense heavy serious but you
know I learned that it's it's important
to to be present and live your life
sorry my phone I've had to turn my phone
off what you're saying is you went
through this intense experience
all right and it taught you that you
know you need to get one life and you
need to yeah I just you know love the
people you're with and enjoy your life
and just to be sorry just just to be
present
my friend sends me the funniest cat
pictures okay so okay so you went to
this you went through this intense
experience which people fear you went
through a harrowing experience where you
thought maybe your life is threatened no
my life it was threatened it just yeah
it's just good to to just you know
appreciate life and and not take
anything for granted and just do you
mind I she has this really funny picture
do you mind if I call her she has a very
funny picture of a cat on her landlords
head that go go ahead that's fine I want
her to send it maybe you could put it up
hey hey what's up hi hey what are you
doing nothing
[Laughter]
yeah I just got him I was just telling
this guy about the I just tell this guy
about the you don't you don't know her I
just just telling us guys about the cat
the picture of the cat on your
landlord's head could you send that one
okay when you see the I need another
shave now my dear throughout while we
were talking to her yeah
[Laughter]
J gets this part here no yeah I'm going
on a national tour I'm also doing some
shows by myself I'm hitting like
Bloomington and Bethlehem and Durham
hitting all the major markets you know
trying to trying to stay relevant and
cigs podcast professor plasti is
available at professor blast-off dot-com
and her album live that's right it's
available on iTunes take note arrow
thank you very much for
[Applause]